I've never seen you get excited over
anything that wasn't dessert what do you
mean you heard me it I get a difference
I get excited for strawberry to
do okay
big difference okay so just I was gonna
say that just ruins my I was going to
ask if you've discovered like a Japanese
dessert that you like but if you don't
like desserts no
um I like
don't say what I just feel I feel like
you're gonna say what I like Mochi okay
okay
I don't know just like the plain one
with like the soy sauce that one's
really good yeah that's just hot but
yeah I don't I don't I don't really like
desserts do you like Ichigo daifuku the
one oh my God yeah okay of course that
was a dumb question
I like to to get it and then get like an
extra pack of strawberry so that when I
run out of strawberry I can stick
another one back in I like reset it's so
good it's so sorry you reload the Mochi
with another strawberry it's so because
there's never one strawberry is not
enough for one Ichigo daifuka you need
yes
what are you talking about Emily goes to
the [__] strawberry farm and just
reloads the entire apartment perfectly
engineered that so the Mochi the
strawberry ratio is like perfect so that
maybe you're left with like a tiny
little bit of emoji at the end no it's
clowns I need more strawberries that is
one of the things that I'm really happy
about since moving here the strawberries
so freaking good yeah except uh they
only come around like once a year yeah
yeah unfortunately Japan is so dependent
especially with fruit they're so
dependent on Seasons we're just like I
don't know man I feel this fruit here is
good enough where you could have it all
year round like I don't think it'd be
that much of an issue really could they
grow it in the winter in the summer I
don't know I mean like I mean I feel
like when you go to like a supermarket
in like any other country I feel this
just like the whole collection of fruits
all year round I don't know yeah but
sometimes the fruit tastes better in
certain seasons of my local grocery
store I can always tell like what season
it is based on oh yeah in Japan I mean
like in different countries yeah yeah
like you go to like any kind of
Supermarket like America or Australia
whatever and it's like they have all of
the fruits there yeah all year round and
I'm like Japan could do that but they're
just like it's not in season let's not
sell it and I'm like because it's not at
its peak yeah I'm like but sometimes
it's like it could be like this right
now winter and I'm like I kind of want
to have some watermelon but they don't
[__] sell watermelon everywhere so
I'm just sad drinking
the amount of like watermelon like
smoothies not smoothies watermelon uh
mixes I don't know like the I've got the
English name the amount of watermelon
drinks you guys got in Thailand was like
[__] ridiculous oh yeah it was either
watermelon or coconuts oh because it's
expensive here very good Coconut's
[__] great I just like the fresh
coconuts yeah same here like very good I
I rarely have coconut if it's not you
know in the Southeast Asian country or
if it's like grown there because I
remember like for a long time Sydney
just like hated coconut and she was she
was like I don't like coconut water I
don't like coconut anything but I didn't
like it either yeah and then and then we
moved to Thailand and she was like I
[__] love coconut and I'm like Sydney
when you're out of the country you're
going to be chasing that high and no
matter what the no matter what coconut
juice coconut water you get it's never
gonna you can't buy the package stuff
ever again no no you're gone it's just
something about that freshness of the
coconut there though yeah you'll spend
your life chasing that high and it will
like no canned coconut drink or whatever
will ever meet up
hmm what's your favorite food in
Thailand I'm curious because someone as
someone who doesn't like strong flavors
and strong taste that's like 90 of Thai
food
well I did Gorge myself on the fruit for
sure because I knew it would be able to
get the same stuff here mango coconut
watermelon was just oh my God the mango
sticky rice
okay mango sticking my [__] slabs
yeah that's like your worth yeah it's
like a worse nightmare Connor every
fried egg I had in Thailand was
delicious yeah crispy everything was
delicious even the stuff that was like
too spicy for me I like I was like damn
this is still really fun yeah it's so
good dude I felt bad in Thailand because
we ordered room service one night
um we brought in this amazing food and
they said it all out for us and it was
it was like way too much yeah from them
I think we'd have been happy they were
just like
your food's here come get it we'd have
done it right yeah and so he brings out
like the thing to tip and I was like oh
yeah I'll tip him yeah sure let's
[__] time write down a number and I'm
like nice we tipped him he leaves I'm
like
oh [__] I just tipped him like 30 cents
you know and then I realized oh [__] I
gave him three like 30 cents and I was
like oh my God and then of course when
we're done with it we call them up right
and yeah man I really wanted to correct
it but I was like man how do I okay can
you come back to the room I've got more
money for you oh they didn't come back
right now we I called so I was like Hey
we're done with the food same dude comes
back and I'm like yeah dude
sorry about that
um he's a real test since I gave him a
bunch and he was like no no no no no no
I'm just I just like doing this it's
fine no no please take it please and
then I was like I got money too I just
faster walking about that sorry that
you've been burning in my memory
we made up for it yeah I wonder what's
more offensive no tip or 30 cents
at least no tip it's like you weren't
even trying [__] pretending like we
bought like a [__] hundred dollar
room service there yeah
probably I would be thinking do they
feel good about this
hotel more than 30 seconds it's like
it's like giving a dollar to the
homeless person be like I've done my
good deal for the day you know I am I'm
a Good Samaritan today
what do you what do you think about um
because you've been in Japan for a while
yeah the the architecture do you
compared to like American one or like
when you're walking do you like how it's
more walkable here or I do oh my God I
love that I don't have to drive
um like why in Tokyo right I was so yeah
I was so happy when I finally like sold
my car and I was like I don't have to
worry about this again I have to pay for
registration yeah for as long as I live
again yeah I can just walk it's great I
love public transportation you think you
might uh try and drive it all here nope
all right
next question any reason for that well I
don't think I could rewire my brain to
be on the other side of the road do you
mean the correct side of the road sure
the correct side of the road I feel like
I don't know I just I I already feel
nervous I feel that way when I think
about every time I go to American I'm
like maybe I should get an international
license but then I think about I'm like
I'm gonna crash yeah yeah if I try I
don't know
I've driven in America before is it
scary
it's [__] terrifying yeah it's holy
[__] I just drive different dude
Americans try that they have nothing to
lose I already didn't like driving in
America like it's just I don't know it's
a scary experience especially if you're
driving in La yeah oh my God yeah if you
don't drive aggressive in L.A like you
just don't get anywhere exactly
aggressive which is terrified I hate I
just like following the rules yeah
driving yeah why does everyone drive
like they have three stars on GTA
it's like what are you running away from
they do they do because they probably do
they probably do yeah I will say like
coming from like a British driving
license because even in Thailand you
drive on the left side of the road as
well intersections are the most
terrifying things I've experienced my
life driving in America just because
there are so
yeah because like I remember everything
like first time I started driving in
America luckily I was driving in [__]
Wisconsin but even in Wisconsin three
other drivers yeah even Wisconsin still
[__] terrifying because I don't know
if like the guy next to me has had like
two pints or whatever or five pints God
knows if it's in Wisconsin you know what
scares me is it how big the cars are in
America yeah when I'm driving like if if
a [__] K car hit me in Japan I'm like
all right well his car gets demolished
maybe I get a bruise in America it's
like we've got the new Chevy t150 built
with industrial Titanium on the front
everything in your past if you need a
ram a liberal off the road it's like
it's like they're gigantic
the trucks yeah like you feel like it's
just any Collision feels like definitely
deadly in America oh yeah when I first
started like when I was new to driving
at like age 19 yeah
um any I don't do it anymore obviously
but anytime I had to like
paths or like drive past like an
18-wheeler I would scream the entire
time
at what point is it like you indicate
you're like
you just put it down
I had to be like a good distance away
that I'm like okay
why with passengers too oh especially
with passengers oh my God I'm like here
we go I'd be like so yeah I'm thinking
like this one
oh
anyway what was I saying uh why
full-on screaming the whole time I
understand screaming in your head yeah
oh but not out loud yeah oh that's just
a psychotic breakdown like no I mean I
got over it I think my mum did a similar
thing actually because she was telling
me when she had driving lessons uh did
you have to like learn emergency brakes
in American like driving school
emergency brakes like the no so so
that's a handbrake yeah look
you need to immediately stop yeah in the
British test you have to there might be
a thing where the guy just goes all
right emergency stop and you're just
full on just don't matter how fast
you're going full-on stop yeah no we
don't know yeah so we won't be on a busy
road no no it would be it'll test you on
a quiet road but they teach you the
technique of how to basically slam the
clutch in a safe manner right so so
you're not like swerving everywhere
um so you sometimes get tested on it in
in British Driving School uh but I
remember my mom telling me that she was
incapable
um every time they would ask her to
practice the emergency stop she wasn't
capable of doing it without screaming at
Full Tilt
so how it goes right is you're driving
on this really quiet Road and then the
instructor will just go stop and
normally you just slam on the brakes but
my mom was telling me every time the
instructor goes stop she's going
they'll take out points for that dude I
think I would
probably a minor right yes something
it's so funny though yeah you said Japan
is very walkable in the cities when you
get out of it it's very very not yes
yeah have you had a chance to like visit
outside of Tokyo a lot because I know
everyone is like moved to Japan I'm like
they're like I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
[__] explore outside of Tokyo I'm
gonna explore so much for Japan a year
passes and you're like I've been nowhere
yeah
times that we have traveled outside of
Tokyo Conor's driven yeah I've been uh
oh okay yeah yeah yeah I love driving in
Japan it's fun you know it's chill it's
way better than public transport oh my
God because you can just listen to music
and like talk uh you can do that on the
train yeah well I'm not like you can't
listen to the music with the boys you
know what I mean you can't blast it come
on you know it's just more fun I guess
because it's like you're so used to
public transport here that when you do
get the chance to have that expert like
the vibe of being in a car with your
friends like yeah hell yeah I'll take
that well it is a lot yeah like it's a
luxury well I mean I think there's a
difference between you know going on a
road trip with the boys and uh commuting
an hour every day via car which a lot of
people do yeah so you know you know
that's that's you know two very
different experiences because there is
there only a vibe that I love about just
blasting the mute like you're in the
driver's seat you're in the driver's
seat and you're blasting the music that
you wanna [__] blast too of course
you know and just like bombing it down
the highway side in Japan when there's
like they got like such cool roads and
like you have really cool like Mountain
uh like Bridges and highways it's just
so cool yeah it's so cool it's a Vibe
yeah it's so fun to drive because I took
it yeah where else are we on
Chiba yeah what you doing what are we
doing Costco oh yeah oh yeah we did you
went to she better go to a concert we
stayed um that's all we do no no no
that was weird that was so weird yeah so
I want to go Costco and then we were
like let's just do like a little Airbnb
where we chill out in the countryside
barbecue and eat Costco food and so we
went
um to me you made it sound like it was
you made it sound like we went to Chiba
just for Costco I'd do that too yeah we
did get that too we went to uh we went
to Costco got a bunch of barbecue stuff
and then went out and then um we went to
Narita which is the airport right yeah
I'd never been to Naruto and I think
most people as well I've never been to
Naruto outside of the airport so we went
to some camping place in Naruto which is
lovely now it's just really nice that
the shrines were awesome it was just a
giant one uh in the city center
um but this the guy who ran the Airbnb
was weird
was nice but he was he came and like
drank with us and then got like hammered
and passed out
so he lived opposite and then he came
over he's like how you guys doing
Japanese guy uh polish I think yeah oh
oh okay he was like so I think he was
just like he lived far away from his
wife or something as well sounded kind
of lonely and it's not like he didn't
have any friends who came over he's like
so hey guys joined the Airbnb here like
yeah that's good we drink him I mean
like Spears like oh okay mind if I join
I'll be like all right sure I guess he
was just nice yeah this was nice it was
nice it was just funny that he passed
out and I know he didn't pass down he's
not trusting us huh yeah yeah I've never
had an Airbnb oh no come yeah that's a
bit weird yeah it was definitely odd it
was definitely like you felt like you
didn't sign up for it yeah but